Vice was pretending to be oh we're here
to deliver the news we're here to be
objective we're and when you don't do
that people aren't stupid they look at
that and they say well I'm just going to
turn this off and I think it was really
interesting because Andrew Tate was
front and center that documentary was
front and center and it was garbage I
mean I did it on my show I analyzed it
piece by piece it wasn't it was just a
manifestation of what was going on there
this deception this manipulation of the
public people are really tired of that
stuff I think Disney is suffering big
time as a result of what they're doing
with the wokeness injected into kids
cartoons and people just want you to be
straight with them if you're a hard left
Progressive as I call it regressive
organization if that's your line if if
you're an MSNBC or just own what you're
doing own your agenda I think a lot of
these uh organizations are getting into
trouble because they're trying to trick
the public